>> HOLD ON, THE JURY IS TALKING.
>> THANK YOU, SIR.
>> IN CIVIL CASE NUMBER CL
20192911, MR. DEPP'S CLAIM
AGAINST MS. HEARD.
1, AS TO THE STATEMENT APPEARING
IN THE ONLINE OP-ED ENTITLED
AMBER HEARD, I SPOKE UP AGAINST
SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND FACED OUR
CULTURE'S WRATH, THAT HAS TO
CHANGE.
IN THE "WASHINGTON POST" ONLINE
EDITION, QUOTE, I SPOKE UP
AGAINST SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
FACED OUR CULTURE'S WRATH, THAT
HAS TO CHANGE, END QUOTE.
DO YOU FIND THAT MR. DEPP HAS
PROVEN ALL THE ELEMENTS OF
DEFAMATION?
ANSWER, YES.
HAS MR. DEPP PROVEN BY A GREATER
WEIGHT OF THE EVIDENCE THAT
QUESTION THE STATEMENT WAS MADE
OR PUBLISHED BY MS. HEARD,
ANSWER YES.
THE QUESTION, THE STATEMENT WAS
ABOUT MR. DEPP, ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE STATEMENT WAS
FALSE.
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE STATEMENT HAS A
DEFAMATORY IMPLICATION ABOUT MR.
DEPP, ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE DEFAMATORY
IMPLICATION WAS DESIGNED AND
INTENDED BY MS. HEARD?
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, DUE TO CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING THE PUBLICATION OF
THE STATEMENT IT CONVEYED A
DEFAMATORY IMPLICATION TO
SOMEONE WHO SAW IT OTHER THAN
MR. DEPP, ANSWER, YES.
DO YOU FIND THAT MR. DEPP HAS
PROVEN BY CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE THAT MS. HEARD ACTED
WITH ACTUAL MALICE, ANSWER, YES.
2, AS TO THE STATEMENT APPEARING
IN THE OP-ED ENTITLED, A
TRANSFORMATIVE MOMENT FOR WOMEN
IN THE "WASHINGTON POST" PRINT
EDITION AND THE ONLINE OP-ED
AMBER HEARD, I SPOKE UP AGAINST
SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND FACED OUR
CULTURE'S WRATH, THAT HAS TO
CHANGE.
IN THE "WASHINGTON POST" ONLINE
EDITION, QUOTE, THEN TWO YEARS
AGO I BECAME A PUBLIC FIGURE
REPRESENTING DOMESTIC ABUSE AND
I FELT THE FULL FORCE OF OUR
CULTURE'S WRATH FOR WOMEN WHO
SPEAK OUT, END QUOTE.
DO YOU FIND THAT MR. DEPP HAS
PROVEN ALL THE ELEMENTS OF
DEFAMATION.
ANSWER, YES.
HAS MR. DEPP PROVEN BY A GREATER
WEIGHT OF THE EVIDENCE THAT
QUESTION THE STATEMENT WAS MADE
OR PUBLISHED BY MS. HEARD.
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE STATEMENT WAS
ABOUT MR. DEPP, ANSWER, YES.
FALSE?
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE STATEMENT HAS A
DEFAMATORY IMPLICATION ABOUT MR.
DEPP.
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE DEFAMATORY
IMPLICATION WAS DESIGNED AND
INTENDED BY MS. HEARD.
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, DUE TO CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING THE PUBLICATION OF
THE STATEMENT, IT CONVEYED A
DEFAMATORY IMPLICATION TO
SOMEONE WHO SAW IT OTHER THAN
MR. DEPP, ANSWER, YES.
DO YOU FIND THAT MR. DEPP HAS
PROVEN BY CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE THAT MS. HEARD ACTED
WITHOUT ACTUAL MALICE?
ANSWER, YES.
3, AS TO THE STATEMENT APPEARING
IN THE OP-ED ENTITLED "A
TRANSFORMATIVE MOMENT FOR WOMEN"
IN THE "WASHINGTON POST" PRINT
EDITION AND THE ONLINE OP-ED
"AMBER HEARD I SPOKE UP AGAINST
SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND FACED OUR
CULTURE'S WRATH.
THAT IS TO CHANGE" IN THE
"WASHINGTON POST" ONLINE
EDITION, QUOTE, I HAD THE RARE
VANTAGE POINT OF SEEING IN
REALTIME HOW INSTITUTIONS
PROTECT MEN ACCUSED OF ABUSE END
QUOTE.
DO YOU FIND THAT MR. DEPP HAS
PROVEN ALL THE ELEMENTS OF
DEFAMATION?
ANSWER, YES.
HAS MR. DEPP PROVEN BY A GREATER
WEIGHT OF THE EVIDENCE THAT
QUESTION, THE STATEMENT WAS MADE
OR PUBLISHED BY MS. HEARD?
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE STATEMENT WAS
ABOUT MR. DEPP?
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE STATEMENT WAS
FALSE?
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE STATEMENT HAS A
DEFAMATORY IMPLICATION ABOUT MR.
DEPP?
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE DEFAMATORY
IMPLICATION WAS DESIGNED AND
INTENDED BY MS. HEARD?
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, DUE TO CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING THE PUBLICATION OF
THIS STATEMENT, IT CONVEYED A
DEFAMATORY IMPLICATION TO
SOMEONE WHO SAW IT OTHER THAN
MR. DEPP?
ANSWER, YES.
DO YOU FIND THAT MR. DEPP HAS
PROVEN BY CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE THAT MS. HEARD ACTED
WITH ACTUAL MALICE?
ANSWER, YES.
AS AGAINST AMBER HEARD, WE THE
JURY AWARD COMPENSATORY DAMAGES
IN THE AMOUNT OF $10 MILLION.
AS AGAINST AMBER HEARD, WE THE
JURY AWARD PUNITIVE DAMAGES IN
THE AMOUNT OF $5 MILLION.
IN CIVIL CASE NUMBER CL
20192911, MS. HEARD'S CLAIM
AGAINST MR. DEPP, 1, AS TO THIS
STATEMENT, APPEARING IN THE
APRIL 8th, 2020, ONLINE EDITION
OF THE DAILY MAIL QUOTE AMBER
HEARD AND HER FRIENDS IN THE
MEDIA USED FAKE SEXUAL VIOLENCE
ALLEGATIONS AS BOTH A SWORD AND
SHIELD DEPENDING ON THEIR NEEDS.
THEY HAVE SELECTED SOME OF HER
SEXUAL VIOLENCE HOAX FACTS AS
THE SWORD INFLICTING THEM ON THE
PUBLIC AND MR. DEPP.
DO YOU FIND THAT MS. HEARD HAS
PROVEN ALL THE ELEMENTS OF
DEFAMATION?
ANSWER, NO.
2, AS TO THIS STATEMENT,
APPEARING IN THE APRIL 27th,
2020, ONLINE EDITION OF "THE
DAILY MAIL" QUOTE, QUITE SIMPLY
THIS WAS AN AMBUSH, A HOAX, THEY
SET MR. DEPP UP BY CALLING THE
COPS, BUT THE FIRST ATTEMPT DID
NOT DO THE TRICK.
THE OFFICERS CAME TO THE
PENTHOUSES, THOROUGHLY SEARCHED
AND INTERVIEWED, AND LEFT AFTER
SEEING NO DAMAGE TO FACE OR
PROPERTY.
SO AMBER AND HER FRIENDS SPILLED
A LITTLE WINE AND ROUGHED THE
PLACE UP, GOT THEIR STORIES
STRAIGHT UNDER THE DIRECTION OF
A LAWYER AND PUBLICIST, AND THEN
PLACED A SECOND CALL TO 911, END
QUOTE.
DO YOU FIND THAT MS. HEARD HAS
PROVEN ALL THE ELEMENTS OF
DEFAMATION?
ANSWER, YES.
HAS MS. HEARD PROVEN BY A
GREATER WEIGHT OF THE EVIDENCE
THAT QUESTION MR. WALDMAN WHILE
ACTING AS AN AGENT FOR MR. DEPP
MADE OR PUBLISHED THIS
STATEMENT?
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE STATEMENT WAS
ABOUT MS. HEARD?
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE STATEMENT WAS SEEN
BY SOMEONE OTHER THAN MS. HEARD?
ANSWER, YES.
QUESTION, THE STATEMENT WAS
FALSE?
ANSWER, YES.
DO YOU FIND THAT MS. HEARD HAS
PROVEN BY CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE THAT THE STATEMENT BY
MR. WALDMAN WAS MADE WITH ACTUAL
MALICE?
ANSWER, YES.
3, AS TO THIS STATEMENT
APPEARING IN THE APRIL 27th,
2020, ONLINE EDITION OF "THE
DAILY MAIL" QUOTE, WE'VE REACHED
THE BEGINNING OF THE END OF MS.
HEARD'S ABUSE HOAX AGAINST
JOHNNY DEPP END QUOTE.
DO YOU FIND THAT MS. HEARD HAS
PROVEN ALL THE ELEMENTS OF
DEFAMATION?
ANSWER, NO.
AS AGAINST JOHN C. DEPP II, WE
THE JURY AWARD COMPENSATORY
DAMAGES IN THE AMOUNT OF
$2 MILLION.